all right so let's shift the discussion
a little bit to the NRA because that was
the other part of this that during the
the townhall and the subsequent
discussions that it got very confused as
to what the NRA actually does what do
they want to do what are the people who
don't like them think they do etc etc so
first off just give me your position on
the NRA generally I think the NRA is a
fantastic organization that defends the
rights the right to bear arms of
individuals saying what the NRA is that
they really don't have the money
influence that people say they do all
they have is the social influence
Republican senators know that the base
believes in the values of the NRA
promotes and defense and they understand
that if they go against the NRA they're
going against their own constituents the
NRA does not have a big budget they
really don't date they're not like this
like super powerful like that they
directly control senators and
congressmen with their money they
control it with their ideals what the
NRA does which is fantastic is it
provides a check from like from the
public not not from the government for
defending our right to bear arms and
it's fantastic you know it helped I
think with the case with McDonald vs
Chicago that helped bolster Second
Amendment rights for individuals I mean
in the NRA does a great job there NRA
ila program which is actually the
legislative branch on defending the
Second Amendment does a fantastic job I
think right now they're taking a case
against raising the age from 18 to 21
there was right for the shooting of Rick
Scott signed into law in Florida raising
the age to buy I think a firearm or a
rifle now so before before you couldn't
buy a handgun if you were under 21 but
you could buy a rifle because handguns
were used in violent crimes whether I
think that's right or not that's a
separate discussion but he raised the
age from 18 21 to buy a rifle and
directly the the NRA was like this is
unconstitutional boom would put on a
lawsuit just to address that 18 to 21
age there is absolutely no evidence that
raising the age does absolutely this
does anything to to lower gun homicide
whatsoever so what do you think about
the certain set of P
I think that if we could just have all
of the right laws or if we could just
manage everything properly that
everything would be fine thing is
because he doesn't take into things we
have have all the laws that we need
already on the books as thing as the
enforcement doesn't work so I'll just
make a tangent I'll get back to here I
think it is utterly hypocritical that
the left hates Trump and they that he's
in power but then they're saying we have
to trust the government more so if you
think the government if you think Trump
is literally Hitler why are you giving
you a right to wear bar arms to this
tyrannical government it was a question
again well just that there's a certain
set of people that think if we just saw
a law I ask you so we already have the
the the laws on the books you know just
the enforcement the enforcement of what
needs to occur like the Lautenberg
amendment means that don't
it says that domestic abusers cannot
have a firearm that's ready on the books
it just needs to be enforced there's the
issue with you know the NICs background
check program where they say we need
more time to to evaluate and give you
back your background check in order to
buy a weapon the issue is the government
doesn't need more time it just needs
more of the records so the reason why
the Texas oil and shooting occurred was
because I think it was some military
branch where there was someone who were
he committed a violation and by law they
the heat they should have transferred
that over to the database and therefore
he would have been able to buy a weapon
but the records weren't transferred he
was able to buy a weapon and he shot up
the church so the government just needs
to get all the records and do their job
same thing with red flag laws um and
people like to talk about this this is a
little bit more the trickier areas of
this but red flag laws basically say
that someone can flag you and then you
get reviewed and then you can get your
gun taken away and a lot of people also
like so the issue with red flag gun laws
is that it's all about government
enforcement and and that's that's that's
the issue and there's also the big issue
where people like to talk about mental
health mm-hmm and they say you're
mentally ill people shouldn't be able to
acquire weapon so I have talked to
countless individuals about this and I
should ask Peterson but I forgot to the
question is how do you determine when
someone is mentally ill enough and hits
the threshold so they cannot have a
weapon and nobody knows and in addition
the thing with the shooter at my school
looking retro
actively we can say this kid was
mentally insane but I don't know if a
court would have judicata he would
actually be mentally insane by by law
therefore kicking his gun away yeah so
is the inherent problem here do you
think that you cannot manage all of
these things you can do the best you can
to have some sensible laws around them
and defend our right to bear arms and
all of that and make sure schools are
taken care of but that generally
speaking yes there's a sort of sliding
scale psychologically but also that the
people that want to do bad will find
ways to do bad they're not the ones that
are walking out and looking at a
building it says oh no guns here yes I'm
not gonna walk in with the gun you
criminals will act like criminals no
matter what but the good thing is that
our laws are working I mean I think it's
violent crime or huh some rate from the
1990s to 2010 has decreased by 50
percent and and pub and schools are
safer now than they were 20 years ago
like school shooting rates are declining
and homicide rate gun homicide rates are
declining and the homicide rates are
declining so we are becoming a more
peaceful nation and a lot of that has to
do with having more gun owners and to
having more no concealed carry permit
owners because those people when there's
a shooting those people are the first
responders I think it's wrong to say
that oh we'll just let the police arrive
after the crime has been committed no
you need people there immediately to
stop the shooter that's why I'm all for
having teachers and armed school
officers at schools to immediately take
down the shooter all right so let's
shift I mean I don't think we're gonna
fully get away from guns here but let's
shift a little bit okay what is it like
to be a 17 year old right now that's in
the mix of this that's now a public
person do not go crazy yeah to just be
part of this this oddly unique time
where it feels like the adults have lost
the plot and it's got to be very hard
for you to find people that kind of make
sense I think you've been able to find a
couple of them but just to be 17 in this
very odd political cultural time yeah
it's insane that's it is insane yeah
like what does it feel unique to you I
know you haven't lived
through this before but like I don't
know how to judge it yeah well all I
know is that I'm an adult now and I have
to act like an adult whether whether I'm
17 or 18 I have committed like
commitments that I make I have to go
through with them and I've just my
maturity I've like forced to become
insured like I can no longer play video
games and waste time there's things that
I have to do but I've just been so
blessed to find a solid group of people
who actually care about me and want the
best for me like like Ben and Charlie
and guy Benson people who have just
reached out to me and I'm just
selflessly helped me navigate this
political minefield but it's crazy cuz
like all the people that I looked looked
up to like two years ago and like would
watch their videos I'm not gonna stop
trying like post you go here but I would
watch your show please continue but yeah
it's awesome that now I can reach out
for their expertise the thing with me is
that I always like to start with look I
don't know anything and I'm always
looking to get more information to know
more like today I had a call with with a
gun expert I'm on the way here and it's
like what more can I learn in order to
be like fully fluent and and in
knowledgeable with the subject that I'm
talking about and there are a bunch of
stuff that I don't know about and I'm
constantly trying to learn so when you
see a guy and again I don't like making
this about people rather than ideas but
when you see a guy like David Hogg out
there and he clearly is taking just the
progressive line on this and he seems
more to me to be sort of a progressive
activist
than sort of a a fair arbiter of what's
going on here that's gotta be
frustrating for you that he's so public
about this I suppose so much so well
that you obviously probably disagree
with him on a hundred percent of the
policy parts this is true yeah I don't
wanna make it about the personal part
but that he's thought of as sort of a
media hero and you're kind of the black
sheep of this group I mean maybe not to
the to the Shapiro's and me and whoever
else so here so here's what I say
there is no issue that kids are on
television the issue is is that when
someone is spouting policy they know
they are no longer a child they are
pushing policy and they should be
treated as every adult as such when you
say
something outrageous you should be
called out on that I remember there's a
segment with it was on CNN where he said
something completely outlandish and
there was no blowback so look here's
what I think was that the line about
Marco Rubio wants to kill kids so what I
say is when I'm pushing policy and I say
thanks Luke please like tell me that I'm
saying something stupid and push me back
on that the thing is with me that look
when I'm on TV I'm not talking as a
child on pushing policy right and I
expect there to be pushback I don't
think you can say whatever you want like
I and in addition I think that having
debate is great so like I love I love
going on Piers Morgan and having a
debate with that was great mm-hmm and I
think we have to I hate this thing we're
like we're one second you're spouting
policy but then you rush back to the
deshield of oh I'm a child but we have
to take my opinion seriously because the
second I say I'm an adult yeah so
justjust this isn't this isn't fair yeah
and what I saw I think one of the
reasons why I grew to such publicity was
because I was saying the things that
adults weren't able to say like I was
able to say things that ben shapiro or
you or charlie kirk or the right wasn't
able to say because i'm a kid and i
don't think that's fair because I think
that when you're spouting policy you
were no longer a child you're an adult
what do you make of what's going on with
the right generally because you ran the
turning point was that the high school
event that I did or yes I've done so
many bicycling ups are you okay so you
did the high school Leadership Summit in
DC and I spoke there this a couple
months ago and you had a great lineup of
speakers and it was there and you had
big big time politicians and and first
up I mean that was the first time we met
and I was like holy yeah we this debate
about abortion yeah okay so that's my
point so first of you you you ran this
whole thing I mean you're you're still
in high school right we're gonna talk a
little bit about where you want to go to
college and all that but you ran an
incredible event with major primetime
people and and it was it was jam-packed
and it was diverse in terms of ideas so
we get into a private debate about
abortion but you brought me there and I
went up there thanks but I I went up
there and I talked about my differences
with this group I talked about
respect yeah and I talked about gay
marriage and abortion and death penalty
and a couple other things that generally
these young conservatives are not for I
think gay marriage they're pretty much
for yeah that the ship has sailed on
that one actually I'm pretty sure I got
a huge ovation on them yeah I think it
but it is just clear to me that there
has been a realignment on the right
where there is exactly what you're so
cute can we just say that Lindsey Graham
2.0 is fantastic oh the guy it's
unbelievable that I mean just that one
the thing with the tie the anything yeah
yeah Benny's do sorry here's the thing I
think the right Daily Caller
so I think the right is finally
realizing that youth and like the
energizing the youth and instilling the
next like future of conservative leaders
is extremely important and we saw that
with the high schoolers of something we
had some of the biggest name speech like
nikki Haley Betsy DeVos we had like
attorney Jeff Sessions we had so many
people and everything we had mark
meadows we had Steve Scalise we had
Swede we had Prager made you and it was
just it was fantastic to see the right
just understand that these are the
leaders of tomorrow let's inform them
but in addition Turning Point is such a
great organization it's free speech free
markets and in capitalism
those are the three Lex uh and what we
saw what turning-point is such a it's
such a great organization because we
were we brought people who I have
disagreements with to speak there Mark
Cuban spoke got a couple standing
ovations had a debate with Charlie and
people loved it so we're all open having
free discussion and debate like we're
working on Sasso shooting action summit
December nineteen twenty second
shameless plug yeah I think and we're
we're looking like how can we get the
most diverse group of people to speak
like I'm thinking about something from
the intellectual dark web to speak there
I think that's great if we can get Alan
Dershowitz just how can we get diversity
of thought so why is it that this new
write or whatever you want to call a
young conservative group whatever it is
why is it that you guys are able to do
this and I see virtually none of this on
your counterparts on the Left that's not
sure I mean the left
organize and mobilize youth this right
now we are well I mean no no but I'm
talking about diversity of thought like
where are they be careful that's all
been mildly disagree with I'm not
talking about scary conservatives I'm
talking about old-school liberals where
where are they inviting them to just
have an interesting congressman the left
is so dead set on political correctness
and saying everything to not offend
anyone with the slightest micro micro
micro aggression that it's just you
can't live in that world and intolerant
like logical liberals like yourself are
moving to the right I like that
these subtle little injections of
pleasantry yeah it's nice are moving
people to the right and conservatives
are like come here my refugees my
political refugees we're embracing you
yeah so okay so when I hear people will
say Rubin the Conservatives are just
using you you go to turning-point
they're just using you you're not just
using me Kyle no I mean yeah but no no
but really I mean what I've seen is
intellectual flexibility here and it's
even when I've had been in here and
we've done this conversation repeatedly
and now about gay marriage I just firmly
believe that as time goes on I can shift
him I there's something that's sort of
insulting about it to me when people say
that to me because I'm confident I'm
confident up in my father I think he's
gonna take you an abortion I really
think that like in a few years you'll be
with us on abortion maybe but you know
what that would be a trade-off right
like if if ultimately I always describe
myself as begrudgingly you know I think
rotation of of homosexuality well I
don't I don't I don't have like a strong
opinion on it cuz I haven't thought
about it enough by his religious
standpoint it makes sense but from a
government standpoint it also makes
total sense well that's why I'm
completely fine with him it's like you
want to have your religious view I have
to respect that but if you were trying
to legislate my life yeah the great
thing with the right is that we're open
to just diversity of thought just say
whatever you want let's talk about it
and let's get to the right rational
viewpoint like I've always been about
debate because it brings people it's all
about logic and it brings people to the
right end result so when I'm on tour
with Peterson the question that I think
both of us get asked more than anything
else is what are the best techniques to
wake people up
of this sort of postmodern identity
politics progressive groupthink as a
young person in the midst of this have
what would you say are some techniques
you've been able to use because it can't
just be about drumming them with facts
right I mean the left is doing a
fantastic job well they're just
craziness and pushing people to the
right so it's just sort of stands in on
themselves um what we saw right now with
Colleen and in addition it's just he was
simply saying freedom of expression
freedom of thought I support the
president our president has to be the
freshest the flyest thought why just
pushing people to diversity of thought
and freedom of expression to think
whatever you want you shouldn't have you
shouldn't be held down by your skin
color or race or you know your sexuality
like none of this matters you should be
able to think what you want and be able
to say it without being tied down by you
know your identity yeah how do you make
sure that you don't get burned out
because I think I remember the first
communication we ever had I think when
either you followed me or I followed you
on twitter I just sent you a quick
one-line note and I was just like just
don't get burned out because I saw you
just you were in the fight everyday you
were you were owned and owned in the
limbs and all that which by the way you
know you mentioned that nikki Haley was
at your summit yeah it's like she went
she went to to you know in effect what
is a lot of Trump people right at this
at this event you put on she goes there
and she says you know don't make this
about just owning the lived yeah and she
got applause for it and I I hit that
same point I think the next day because
I think if you guys do exactly what you
just laid out just kind of stand there
and be cool and be decent you you will
get decency wins I think I honestly
believe the Thiessen C wins can we just
take a second to say that nikki Haley is
fantastic and I yeah I kind of cried for
like a week ever since she said that
what do you think that this is perhaps
paving the road for her running at some
point I don't know there's so many 40
chests like theories I just know I just
I know that she's just been doing a
fantastic job yeah and she's just one of
the best I know nikki Haley Ben Shapiro
2024 yeah I mean I'd probably have to be
press secretary at that point yeah that
would work for like one horrific week
and then I do know but all right so give
me give me some of the techniques when
you see the
it can't just be about standing still
and facts if you're if you're in a
conversation with a young person that's
really just bought into all of this what
are some of the techniques you use so
that's great have you been successful
I suspect that yeah sometimes yeah I
think I have the first thing you have to
realize is that is this person looking
tapping an open discussion and actually
once sorry about that talking a lot
these days it's alright I don't sue much
or actually wants to develop their point
of view if they do you have to treat it
with decency and respect and not calling
them an idiot or something you have to
treat them like a like a good human
being should and then just have a
rational conversation with them and see
where they're coming from and a lot of
times I I can immediately know what
they're gonna respond to me like just
straight off the bat I know what they're
gonna respond to me and I hit them with
with an initial here's an aside here's
the reason there's a shock yeah but then
do you get them around I mean do you
find cuz it really it's like sort of
deprogramming somebody out of this and
I've had some success at it right and I
watch my show now so yeah I mean when I
first heard speaking out kids would come
up to me in school and two things they
would say be like Kyle I'm a
conservative so the thing about school
was really interesting I would get stair
downs and like people like like try to
beat me up so people would like send me
like hey Kyle watch out so and so I was
trying to beat you up I was like alright
man and go for yeah and people would
give me stair downs and there was such a
villain ization of being conservative
being second amendments more when I
spoke up I kind of opened the crack for
people to say oh I agree with him people
would water off to me and like hushed up
like Kyle thank you so much for doing
I'm just scared to speak out and in
addition people say Kyle I thought I was
pro-gun control and you spoke and I
listened to you and then I did some more
research and I agree with you so that
was great to see and like that's just
that's all I'm here for so then to have
people you know understand conservatism
and understand the Second Amendment it's
got to be pretty weird that you guys are
still in high school right like now
you're you're celebrities in the most
strange sense of celebrity you are and
you're all still in high school together
what is that like I mean at the end of
day we have to remember that were kids
and I will explain it so you guys don't
think I'm hypocritical
when you're on TV and you're spouting
politics you're an adult but in your
private life you're a kid and we cannot
forget that so let's say you know when
someone some kid on the Left does
something that's stupid it's at the end
they they're a kid and we have to
address it at such but but it's it's
been a crazy world win and I think thank
God I found a solid group of people who
want the best for me that I can reach
out you know just not for policy but
I've also like personal advice like III
out I asked Ben hey how do you think I
should approach College absence of a
conservative you know and he helped me
out and it's just it's so great to be
able to reach out to people and have
them you know give you advice from like
look 20 years older than me and given me
that advice that they had to go through
yeah what was that great tweet so you're
like number one in your class right not
like number one you are no moaners yeah
correct there was some tweet that you
had about that I'm awesome yeah whoa
what was that number one yeah
and people got so angry because so angry
and they're like we're gonna boycott
graduation so I was like yeah more cake
great yeah it was great and then you
know this the next what was the reason
they wanted to boycott because number
one right so then the semester updated
and then I was still number one as I
posted another tweet about that and that
also blew up and I was like we're gonna
get Ben Shapiro to come Dana lash is
gonna come yeah it's gonna be fantastic
Chris Cox was like yeah I'm gonna be
there but why would they well I mean is
that really how sort of polarizing ly
crazy this has got yes at a high school
level just because they don't like I
mean you're number one not by by it
being ordained no unto you your number
one out of clearly a lot of hard work
and smarts and all that yeah you'd think
that there would be a certain respect
for that that it's said that we have we
are no longer able to be friends with
people like it's sad that people in the
left think so people on the left think
that you're a Republican therefore
you're evil and that's sad that you're
not allowed to be friends with people
who have different political viewpoints
and you're like my best friend is a
liberal and I actually brought onto the
turning-point event
after he was like you know what Kyle
some awesome people made this good pass
I was like yeah I told you yeah but he's
still liberal he's an old-school gamer
oh that's cool
he's probably well getting their union
boom yeah all right so wait let's talk a
little bit about college okay so you're
you're doing a great job in high school
clearly now you've got a public profile
grades are great seemingly you could get
in to wherever you want to go and do it
yeah yeah so do you really think that
that'll play a role in the schools that
you're able to get into yeah absolutely
it's sad to say but but there is a bias
against conservatives especially like
the top tier schools like right now I'm
looking to apply to Ivy's I'll be great
to get into Harvard or Columbia
I really think man you'd be The
Reckoning of those please I really see
I'd be awesome I really think that I
think it's really important to be
accredited you know I might I've been
thinking about Georgetown or GW to work
on the hill I think that's great
um but you know I really I really don't
know what's next for me I really don't
know it's go to college I'm definitely
gonna stay with turning-point it's a
great organization I'm still gonna be
conservative don't worry we're not gonna
change generally people don't go the
other way right you're not gonna
suddenly grow up and be like nah that's
no no I'll go to feelings things that
that usually does that won't happen yeah
but all right so you want to go to
school but you really do think that your
your politics could affect I guess you
know they don't well what happened with
David hog right he didn't get into to
all I don't know what his grades are but
like he didn't get into a whole bunch of
schools right I mean there have been
rumors that he got into Harvard at
Northeastern they wouldn't surprise me
yeah yeah and what do you want to study
you have any idea
it's either business or law I really
don't know yet I just you know I've
always liked like business and I think
law is just absolutely phenomenal I
really don't know yet but you know it's
gonna be great to be in a college campus
where you know everyone is just really
liberal that'll be fine it's sort of
weird and I guess this shows a little
bit about the way the college
experiences is going but in a bizarre
way just knowing you from a little bit
that I know you it's like in a way it's
almost like you don't have to go to
like definitely gonna call yeah well I'm
not saying you shouldn't and I think
there's all sorts of social reasons that
somebody should go and you can you know
you learn in all sorts of other ways
that aren't necessarily academic but
it's like clearly you've got the
academic thing down and can keep
learning that way so it's all you know
it's bizarre that people spend you know
20 grand a year to go to college when
nobody's I mean the sad thing is we're
surrounded by a lot of great minds is
what I'm saying
I'm with you but the issue with college
is that you're basically paying to get
your so brainwashed with stupidity and
that's our part because there are
actually great things to learn in
college just not like lesbian dance
theory like that says that a lot because
some of these classes are just useless
and you know and just it's just
straight-up complete stupidity a lot of
stuff that they're teaching there so
what do you make of how this seems to be
a through line through education and I
mean high school education college
education clearly the media like all of
the sort of brainwashing stuff that
you're talking about it's always going
against people like you and I see you on
Twitter you you take down CNN all the
time you take down mainstream unity all
the time of fun people know my thoughts
on this it's like I just wish like to me
if these we just address that Twitter
just Twitter's for fun we have to stop
taking it or associate so I can your bio
your bio is perfect
Twitter is not real life it's not real
life but peep but the weird thing about
that is it's starting to leak into real
life I I did a direct message like a
year and a half ago or so about how
online culture is becoming mainstream
culture and I think that that really is
what's happening here Twitter's not real
life but it's starting to like leak out
into everyone's conversations on Fox
News and CNN and MSNBC are basically
Trump's Twitter like Twitter is like you
know like have you seen shows where they
basically read random replies to
messages it's like John Smith 3.74 this
like that and it is so stupid but the
biggest thing that we're seeing right
now is is a cultural shift with the
youth like memes think memes have so
much power and are do matter
memes won a lot of memes helped so much
for the Trump's 2016 campaign
yeah with it really did and social media
has a huge influence on our beliefs in
our actions and that's why it is so
scary to see censorship of conservatives
online because that is basically like
Twitter is basically the new version of
you just like yelling into a crowd yeah
and that's basically like the main form
of everyone's communication and shutting
that down is like heavily restricting
you know I haven't developed my full
opinion on this but it seems as such
restricting this restricts your like
really restricts your First Amendment
right yeah so this is the whole issue
about whether they're publishers or
platforms yeah the big issue I don't
know if saying that's right but I think
one of the things if there are certain
if there or if they're published further
than like they have a lot of legal
liability if they're a platform then and
everyone should say whatever they want
but that's not the case so just like
pick one yeah
and they're just completely censoring
conservatives like I know Prager you
gets like their videos demonetized so
much and have your videos gotten to you
monetize they probably yeah well I now
it's gotten a little bit better but our
videos just don't go out to feeds
anymore I went on that career they don't
have the rhythms yeah that crazy rampage
I went on where I just started
retweeting real people I only did it
with real people with real name saying
they've been unsubscribed and they're
getting hundreds and sometimes thousands
of retweets and I'm tagging YouTube and
they just ignore me yeah and it's like
come on guys yeah I mean a little Google
Facebook and Twitter all have proven
biases proven yeah how worried are well
so it's a way interesting to me because
you you never you didn't grow up in a
time when there was some sort of
trustworthy seemingly trustworthy level
of the media like CNN was not always
this the reason I don't even know if you
know this but the reason I think that so
many people like me that are older than
you
attack CNN the most is cuz CNN used to
be decent like MSNBC saying we lean left
yes yeah and CNN saying that and it's
like no you're not
we know exactly what you're doing and
that's why I always tack CNN cuz it's
like you guys have actually become the
worst in the name of everything the
ratings are like oh all of them are like
the lowest it's like a block of red CNN
yeah so here's what I think I think that
a lot of young people and like
make an average Americans do not trust
the media anymore and they have sought
out individuals instead so they trust
individuals so they look to you they
look to Ben they they look to guy Benson
you know Charlie Kirk for for their news
because they trust the individual right
do you see a great risk in that too
because I'm worried about that also but
but the thing is what that is that you
have absolute liability for what you say
you know CNN can come whip something up
or you know but when when an individual
like tweets something it's on like
they're responsible for their actions
yeah so one of the things I've been
saying lately is that I'm actually in a
bizarre way less interested in politics
now than I've ever been but I'm
interested in what you referenced a
little while ago this culture thing
I mean culture and where does it
cultures politics is downstream from
culture yeah that's so true yeah so do
you see that really as as sort of the
future of all this that it's not going
to be about all of the little
machinations of politics it's just going
to be about I mean this I guess this is
the strength of Trump well what you'd
argue it's either the strength or the
the worst part of Trump I suppose that
he's a cold but he's a cultural thing
not necessarily a political thing no I
mean there are pros and cons to that but
we just we have to play by the rules
that are set by society and these are
the rules these are the rules that
culture has a massive impact on society
and whether I like it or not that Kanye
is a Kanye speaking out first of all I
think it's great to be speaking out his
First Amendment right I don't think we
should be propping up opinions by
celebrity symptom because they're famous
you have to show that you are informed
on the subject and that's that but it
doesn't take a political genius to say
that I believe in our Second Amendment
in our First Amendment that doesn't take
but Taylor Swift doing like a 7,000 page
write essay you know that makes
absolutely no sense and contradicts
itself written by like a liberal you
know worker on the hill that I was
disappointed in that just because I have
no particular feelings about her won I
don't know why I don't think I could
name one song or whatever but it's just
like the fact that she stayed out of
politics I liked I was like oh whatever
she's doing or whatever her handlers are
saying
I kind of like it and then she got in on
this and it's like I don't care which
way she was gonna break I was just like
uh we just this is not what we need yeah
I mean a Taylor Swift effect president
is like down Marsha Blackburn love so
thanks Taylor Swift yeah no but but what
we saw right now by the left is that
they are losing their stranglehold on
culture and that is very frightening for
them and we saw that with Kanye when
Kanye started speaking out I gave my
speech about this and they started off
with mob tactics that didn't work
emotional appeal the TMZ guy was
basically begging him when Kanye please
men take take off your hat man it hurts
me emotionally it was like no it's my
first time owner I'm not taking it off
and then we saw just blatant racism yeah
viola character assassinations and still
so that's a disgusting you were not that
how does that fly he wouldn't bow down
to the mob absolutely wouldn't but but
no they're losing their stranglehold on
culture and whether I like that we are
putting so much emphasis on my cultural
icon those are the rules them the rules
like say that on Twitter a lot but this
is this is this is the reality that
we're living in and we have to
understand that and what's happening
with Kanye is a real shift especially
for african-americans and people who are
liking Latinos they're basically saying
I don't know why this controversial
blacks don't have to be Democrats you
don't own me
that's what they're saying basically
it's all he's saying and he has created
such a like a pivotal moment that says
you you're you don't your stranglehold
doesn't affect me because I know what
Hollywood like the second you say
something like I remember someone said
Ben Shapiro is a nice guy his career was
destroyed by Mark Duplass who's a friend
of mine he's been on this show and he
had to issue an apology and it's like
you know oddly what is the world the
idea of people people came to his
defense at first basically saying you
know you should be allowed to say that
yeah and then unfortunately he is black
and black especially young blacks are
saying look they look up to Kanye West
they millions look up to him and they
say this individual why does this
individual think this way and even more
so he didn't bow down to the mob which
is fantastic
dick and we're seeing like a real shift
I don't know the 38 percent number were
38 percent african-american boomer Trump
I don't know if that's necessarily true
all I know is that there was a three
percent jump from there was in August
the black approval rating of Trump was
three percent one of the latest polls
that I know a month ago was 10 percent
so there's a big jump you know we're
seeing that so many young
african-americans are so energized like
I know turning-point is doing a black
Leadership Summit like a week in the
White House mm-hmm we're gonna get just
400 african-american young individuals
to be able to speak there since to be
able listen and to see that the left is
losing their stranglehold on culture and
it is scary for them because that is the
one thing that they have left all right
I got two more for you all right
you are you in the prediction game at
all what do you think is gonna happen in
these midterms we got coming up so what
I've been hearing is that Republicans
didn't lose it in the house and gained
in the Senate
I love how I'll cause your work as is
that we're gonna win back the executive
these sounds very confused about all
your clothes yeah but look the Cavett
effect is real yeah like this was like
the all the left had to do was sit down
be quiet be civil play nice to like no
no this is we're not gonna allow this
okay and they hid themselves in a foot
with the club and then there started
crying and they did the same thing with
Kanye that was great so the Kavanagh
really amped up and energized the
conservative base and even more so it
finally gave the conservative like the
Conservatives a backbone like greens a
game Lindsey Graham 2.0 yeah where is
this guy bin yeah I love it and like
Bill Cassidy's but but here's it appears
the interesting thing women were the
most angered by all of this before the
Kavanagh in August it was like thirty
five point seven percent approval of
Trump after was a forty point seven and
before in August the Democrats had a
twelve point lead over Republicans in a
voter enthusiasm
now it's sixty four percent Republican
sixty five Democrats so we are neck and
neck in this and it's all thanks to
Democrats yeah I mean my gut as long as
you're doing predictions here I actually
think the Republicans etre do well in
both the House and the Senate I really
hope so
but I do think so because I agree I
think this mob mentality and watching
these videos of antia and Portland and
Hillary saying we can't be civil and
Eric Holder saying
megalo eject them and it's like man if
you stand for due process and civil
society and all of those things that
thing needs to burn it kind of sucks but
it's like that that set of ideas the
left thinks the left just completely
disregards the Constitution the
Constitution was written and and like
the amendment the Bill of Rights was
forced by anti-federalists to make sure
that the government could not become
tyrannical and abuse its power and this
is so important it's protecting the
rights of the individuals and these
rights why why do we not all agree on
them why is it wrong to believe nude
process why is it wrong to say I believe
that individual should have the right to
defend themselves and also defend
against the tyranny of a possible
government look second man was basically
written because the founders had just
fought against Great Britain and they
had seen how a tyrannical government
quickly become so one more thing I
didn't know the first thing tyrannical
governments do is they take away the
weapons of the civilians so this a Nazi
Germany we saw this in China we saw this
in in Cambodia that's the first thing
they do and the individual right to bear
arms is every individual it's not
related to the militia clause so it's
basically saying every individual has
the right to protect themselves and even
more so it's it's necessary for the
protection of a free state all right one
more for you hit me wait you don't play
video games as much I don't because you
don't have time what do you do for fun
then what's fun I used two sides Twitter
you can't just tell me Twitter I know
you haven't put on Twitter but it can't
just be Twitter what are you doing for
fun so with me I used to play a lot of
video game game so here's here's my
progression I haven't said this but this
is like a scoop World of Tanks
okay it then moved to to rocket League
okay it's suck it's terrible game that's
boring then it moved too so I played
overwatch it played paladin's I played
pub G and then I played for night and
for night this was when all the shooting
occurred and I just stopped dead in my
tracks because it was just it's a waste
of time and I see my younger brothers
who are addicted to the game and it's
just sad to see that this is the state
of our youth that they're just
completely addicted picnic now
like I'm sure if I have kids okay
they're not saying a phone till they're
12 you know they do to call me or 9-1-1
that's a no video games you're reading a
book I don't care so what do you do for
fun you just like you told me what you
used to do come on you must be having
fun somewhere you're having fun
sometimes wow I got you yeah man yeah no
but you're you are having fun with this
yeah some of some of the remaining
friends that I have which are really
solid friends you know when weekend's we
hang out we go watch movies and stuff
like that in addition I just think it's
great one of the greatest things for me
for having fun is just simply talking to
like-minded kids like young individuals
at these turning-point events that we
run and it's great I like meeting with
pushing policy and stuff like that it's
just fantastic like one of the greatest
feelings ever was like passing the stop
school violence act and fix Nick's like
the stops Kevon Zac appropriated funds
to billion dollars in funds for the
protection of schools like hardening
schools metal detectors making better
communication with law enforcement
training law enforcement teachers and
students in addition there was a clause
that said none of this money will be
used for firearm or firearm trainings so
this was like the greatest win for the
left and they still hated the bill and
like the March for Life kids hated it
but no I mean I'm really dead set on
making sure that school shootings just
are thing of the past they never happen
again
and you love what you do have a job just
like just learning about Second
Amendment and just like being more
knowledgeable and having these debates
and discussions or just like they really
make my day yeah well I think it goes
without saying I mean I think you have
an absurdly bright future thank you like
you're gonna run for president or saying
probably not no no but you left a little
window yeah no I mean I little window
maybe there's a thing for politics in
like the hill in the future right now
I'm dead set going to college getting my
degree learning ah staying the political
sphere but uh you know who knows
I'm definitely supporting nikki Haley
Shapiro 2024 though all right you see
people there is hope for the future for
more on Kyle follow them on twitter at
kyle tissues
[Music]